we have a picture here of you and your
carrot as your character an idea from
Russian doll and you really have
Comaneci yeah oh great gymnast great
gymnast and this is such a specific look
and in it really does actually look like
you'd be nice to be in that wardrobe
because you could just hang out in that
wardrobe yeah dead winter and so well
what happened there wonderful costume
designer Emmy nominated Jen Rogan who
did orange is the new black and she said
you know who is this character and I
said she should be like the perfect
marriage of Joe Pesci and Marissa Tomei
from my cousin Vinnie I said this is a
true a character who marries masculine
and feminine well wears black clothing
well the camera doesn't love black but
I'm glad I fought for it it works for
the show so you're saying if Joe Pesci
and racism a had a child in that movie
yeah then it would be this character
you're playing that outfit yes yes yes
yes very good yeah I can actually see
that yeah makes sense to me yes I wanna
fall into this yeah I put a lot of
thought into most things but you'd never
know it